faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
c'est le mot d'ordre de lutte ouvrière
le parti de nathalie arthaud
ex-candidate à la présidence de la
république a présenté ses douze
candidats dans les yvelines ingénieurs
ou ouvriers
chacun d'eux est porté par l'envi de
révolutionner le monde du travail on se
présente au nom de lutte ouvrière pour
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
dans la continuité de la campagne des
présidentielles de nathalie arthaud
c'est eux qui font tourner la société
c'est eux qui fabriquent tous les
bénéfices des grandes entreprises
donc il faut absolument qu'ils expriment
leurs intérêts qui leur sont propres
dans ces élections législatives parmi
les sources de colère des candidats la
loi travail d'emmanuel macron lutte
ouvrière estime que les travailleurs
sont exploités par une société
capitaliste
ils défendent une vision communiste
l'augmentation des salaires pas un
salaire en dessous pas un salaire mais
une pension de 1800 euros nets 300 euros
d'augmentation pour tous
l'interdiction des licenciements la
répartition du travail entre tous sans
diminution de salaire des candidats qui
souhaitent parler au plus grand nombre
même en dehors des yvelines pour olivier
augustin candidat dans la troisième
circonscription
les enjeux sont les mêmes c'est
exactement les mêmes qu'au niveau
national parce que ceux qui vivent et
dans la troisième circonscription il
travaille dans toute la région
parisienne ils ont de la famille un peu
partout en france comme moi et du coup
on est tous concernés par tout ce qui se
passe et y compris dans les yvelines
bien sûr par ailleurs et du coup les
attaques deviennent vraiment de tous les
côtés quoi et c'est pour ça qu'il est
vraiment urgent urgent que nous les
travaillons se fassent entendre dans la
2e circonscription des yvelines
hélène janissaires représentera lutte
ouvrière pour la 10ème ce sera marié
elle souligné et christine & gas dans la
11e circonscription dans le fief de
benoît hamon